about muscles that need work I'm talking
about internal organs I'm talking about
things that no don't don't know
I'm gonna let you land I'm gonna let you
land like muscles you need to work
things need to be strengthened but
there's a resting period that's really
important and I think if we can apply
that like emotionally we might not look
at the word healing or working on self
as such an alien concept we have to look
at the body sometimes and the spirit and
the mind right anyway I'm coming with
all that holistic stuff so but also
healing right the definition of healing
is like so so something's been damaged
it heals and then it goes back to its
somewhere near its original
functionality it's not really healing if
you go on a healing Journey now you're
less capable of loving you less capable
of bonuses you're more judgmental you
know it just sounds you're more into
yourself you start saying stuff like um
me time I mean honestly I think it's
more honest to just say you're damaged
from every heartbreak but then that's
right
it's not that you're not going to heal
from man like this you might you might
improve but like there's no going back
once you've been yeah no no no you don't
you're not you're not gonna okay you're
not gonna be better out of as a virgin
at 18. or you know I'm telling you all
maybe earlier I don't know 16. and
you're a virgin then you've had three
boyfriends and they all broke up maybe
one or two was toxic you're not gonna be
better after you're worse
you're you're a worse product but you're
you should put yourself on sale
even have like completely damaged their
cartilage and they decided to change
their lifestyle change their diet get
alternative therapy and their cartilage
well it's okay that's regenerated I'll
give you an example so that's like a car
right that maybe you repainted it
a potential to regenerate itself it's
not not really but that's why this
sounds no okay you gotta let me talk and
we're gonna like not really like you
can't you can't you can't go through
three toxic relationships and come out
better you're worse put yourself on sale
and like that's honest
and like so when guys here when guys
hear healing like it's like a car okay
if it's got issues under the hood you
might be able to fix it but it still has
a history of issues under the hood and
you can repaint it and make it look
better but it's still a worse product
and it gets put on sale yeah so after a
certain point you've had so many
relationships you put yourself on sets
it's okay then and like honestly you
should have like it it's a sign of ego
if you say I can't put myself on sale
like who are you I don't know I just I
think maybe because my mindset is always
spiritual first like I come from a very
spiritual perspective of things so I
just feel like so if I was to say I'm
damaged okay I can say I'm damn image
but then I'm that's not going to be my
story because I don't want that to it
will be your story it will be part of it
yeah
I don't want it to be the thing that I'm
like oh I'm damaged so therefore I can't
do you know what I mean
it's just like like this is part of your
CV so when you give someone your CV and
it's like oh toxic relationship I was so
toxic I had to cut all my friends off
for six months they're like okay red
flag okay maybe like this is this girl's
maybe a 10. now she's an eight now she's
a seven now she's a six whatever it is
and so it's like that's what I'm saying
once you go through [__] you put
yourself on sale and that's at least
honest go ahead then I was thinking like
when you broke up you consider that
break up as a failure like a personal
failure it is and yeah but at the same
time I truly believe that I learn with
failure you can learn a lesson so I can
improve myself with the breakup yes I
will be damaged I'll go to the next next
relationship with our baggage and
they're still going to be damaged but at
the same time if I take the lesson I can
learn from that yeah so you can improve
yourself in a way that's valuable to
women but not to men there's nothing
after a toxic relationship is going to
make you better because you've had sex
with more people
you've been in more talk you probably
have more toxic habits from it and
you're older so the things that men
value you're you're offering nothing
maybe to you it might be better but
that's like a woman's point of view
because we prefer men with experience
and lived experience because then they
know how to deal better with women
because we're all crazy
so so you it's like and that's common
you're not like the only one that's come
on the show and you know said that but
it's it's like it's a very much a
woman's point of view is and where man
is just like oh that's baggage
yeah yeah it's quite clear as well that
like you if you talk about if you if you
mention something like you know the
healing thing and it's a toxic guy to me
all that says is that guy had an impact
on you in it like no matter how she's
trying to act like yeah you know I've
heard them different now I'm thinking
yeah yo yeah my 50 years my death but
she's gonna be like you know but I just
want to talk to him one more time
I think this idea of you can definitely
heal
um and retain you know a lot of your
value but I think you have to have the
right mindset and today people are so
self-obsessed that they they take it
into the more the ego driven bit so
every time they're healed they're like
I'm better I'm better now I'm better I
deserve more and it's like no you're not
in fact you know you deserve laughs
instead of saying I'm better maybe it
should be I'm gonna do better no not I'm
better because you're right in what
you're saying once you're damaged you
are damaged that's not gonna go anywhere
you can paint it in whatever color you
want you can make it pretty and all the
rest of it once you've had a bad
experience that is going to be then it
will go with you
but then what comes in is who you meet
how that person decides to deal with you
yeah
she said I mean you can meet someone
that might be a bit sensitive towards
you you might meet someone that isn't
sensitive
that makes a difference can I just add
to you said something about how on the
spiritual side like you're allowed to
kind of repent I don't whoa no I don't
know is that what you meant uh no
because repentance is basically saying
okay I'm now absolved from all my sins
okay cool but I I understand the whole
religious aspect but my mind's more like
spiritual and you said you can kind of
cleanse like yeah you can cleanse so and
so my point would be for the cleansing
bit like you still have mileage on the
clock yeah you know what I mean yeah so
whether you've cleansed or not these
things have happened but does the
mileage sit in you though yeah yeah yeah
yeah
if you're if your situation put you to a
mileage of sixty thousand whether you
cleanse or not you're still at sixty
thousand maybe you're not trying to get
any more but like you you still at 60
000 you don't go back you can't reset
the meter on your car I don't know I
think I just have this thing about the
mind like if you could if you program
the mind to do but I get what you're
saying at the same time that's a woman's
point of view no because because women
women like a guy that's had a past and
like been through some [__] and now he's
come out better because men have to
create their value where women are born
with value
big folks so yeah so you're you're born
you're giving the golden ticket at 18.
even even now you like you guys are
early 30s mid-20s like life is hard for
men they grow up being ignored most of
their life and so whereas women we're
given attention like what when's the
first time yeah when's the first time
you had a guy hit on you 13 14 15
something yeah yeah yeah and and so we
don't even realize how hard the world is
for men and how easy it is for us where
we can like spout nonsense and nobody
says anything that's true and we could
like use all these words and I it like I
had to listen a lot to men before I
understood what they were talking about
but I'm like yeah we talk a lot of
nothing do you know what it is I just
feel like the disconnect is like
I feel like some of you are establishing
what makes you a better person whereas
she's talking about what makes you a
better partner you know what I mean so
it's like a better person doesn't
necessarily make you a better partner
okay so that makes so much sense
actually I think it's both actually
because I think a lot of the time
yeah I already made this point right
about what what people tend to be think
think of as making themselves a better
person it's just more a more ego driven
yeah exactly I think the sign that
someone's healed and someone's overcome
something is that it becomes
insignificant to them you know someone
came out say I'm a piece I'm a piece of
my piece I know you're definitely not a
piece